I'm a big believer in like shame only
exists in the shadows which is like once
you put it in the light you look at it
and you're like my mom that was really
it it's not even just my mom it's my mom
in this circumstance when I come back
home for Thanksgiving I just am so
afraid of the comment that she's going
to make it's like well what if we
confront that your mom you sit down at
Thanksgiving dinner and you haven't made
money yet and you quit your job now what
is that better than you spending the
next 60 years hating her or resenting
her for the fact that she held you back
and then it's like when you give the
real scenario they're like and then like
this weight comes off and they're like
I guess I should do this and you're
like yeah